foreign
[Music]
this is unusual to get in such a large
area from coast to coast it's
unprecedented in our modern record
this is quite serious over 340 000
people die prematurely globally every
year due to Wildland fire smoke
good
[Music]
we are seeing more fire because of
human-caused climate change I can't be
any clearer than that Western United
States has seen a quadrupling of area
Burns since the 1970s Canada has seen a
doubling of area Burns since the early
70s and this is largely not solely but
largely attributed to human-caused
climate change generally the warmer it
is the more fire we see because warmer
weather means longer fire seasons